non non
Les Chroniques de la haine ordinaire
[Musique]
Je possède un berger allemand
coucou je suis possédé par un berger
allemand
depuis cet animal partage ma vie j'ai
entendu proférer tant de sottise raciste
à son endroit que je me sens tenu
aujourd'hui de faire une mise au point
permis de retomber calamiteuse des
ridicules les événements estudiantin de
mai 1968 un certain nombre de lieux
communs écologique zoo animalier qui
sont autant de contrevérités aisément
démontable sans cric continuer à moi de
circuler parmi les anciens combattants
de ces monôme qui vient répondre tu
encore en chevrotant leur béatitude baba
cool entre dans les sinistres couloir en
béton des maisons de la cucul moribonde
idée toute faite mais qui ont la vie
dure
selon lesquelles par exemple tout
individu qui tond la pelouse ou qui des
herbes ses sous bois et une brute
herbicide
alors que Crétins chlorophylle et que
vous êtes nous n'aurions plus la moindre
forêt si des générations de nettoyeur
Sylvestre n'en n'avez régulièrement et
systématiquement extirper les ronces et
les orties nous n'aurions plus le
moindre jardin pour vos orgie
végétarienne si des lignes et de sabre
heure de grève n'avait jamais martyrisé
la terre se sont hélas les mêmes débile
écolo confit d'amour tremblant pour les
bébés phoques et les punaises des bois
qui ont décidé une fois pour toute que
les Bergers Allemands étaient des bêtes
féroces
la seule bête féroce qui existent au
monde s'appelle Marcel elle se tient sur
ses pattes de derrière pour aller au
bureau et au lieu de se contenter de
pisser autour de son territoire pour
signaler les frontières elle préfère
défendre les siennes avec des rats
pierre et des armes à feu
éperdu d'amour pour ses prédateurs
bipède à béret bas qui leur jette les
épluchures à la gueule depuis des
millénaires les chiens ne savent que les
lécher les papouilles et leur faire la
fête le berger allemand qu'on a surnommé
chien-loup pour [ __ ] la trouille aux
agneaux
et le plus désespérément dévoué à
l'homme lequel on profite parfois pour
le dénaturé et en faire son complice de
guerre son fils privé ou son bourreau
personnel les heures de vert-de-gris de
naguère notamment se sont montrés assez
expert dans l'art de dévoyer l'énergie
mordante des bergers allemands vers les
fonds de culottes de leur maigre victime
mets des SS il en subsiste encore
aujourd'hui il y en a plein les
pavillons de banlieue nostalgique des
ordres noir affolé par tout ce qui bouge
et qui n'a pas de certificat de baptême
Savoie des bandits et des happy par tout
ça est derrière des huisseries blindé et
ça cotise Alami liste communale des
serrures de fesses des phares et souvent
ces nantis d'une femelle à moustache à
sensibilité de quelque chose
insaisissable au lit et castratrice à
table alors pour se venger pour avoir
l'air plus grand et moins ratatiné ça ça
BRI derrière un berger allemand
le soir à l'heure où les employés de
banque normaux se met des
porte-jarretelles pour épater la femme
de ménage et sa belle-sœur Thérèse ça
descend dans sa cave en tirant le gros
chien au bout d'une corde raide ça sent
au bled une blague ça sans fil dans les
bottes de cuir et dans des blousons
rembourré et s'adresse le bon gros chien
qu'on qu'on a la tuerie sécuritaire
mise à jour le bon gros chien qu'on
qu'on en a à la truffe de sauter à la
carotide d'un mannequin de son qu'il y a
rien fait le foie et finit par le cuir
le sous poil c'est vieux instinct de
fauve enfoui sous des siècles de
servitude aux droits de l'homme lui
remonte soudain au babines la vue
brouillée par la fureur il se trompe de
gorge à saigner alors la bouture de
nazis que le chien-loup as I pousse des
cris stridents de cochon qu'on abat et
le lendemain le journal local annonce
encore un paisible retraités dévorer par
un berger allemand
et ça que voulez-vous c'est très très
mauvais pour l'image de marque de
Rintintin
bien sûr il existe en quantité infime
des bergers allemands qui naissent aussi
féroce que des fachos français de même
qu'on a vu des maquerelle Vallone aussi
plate qu'il me reste le monde
mais c'est extrêmement rare et c'est
souvent le fruit de trituration
génétique de marchand d'animaux peu
scrupuleux qui ne craignent pas de
provoquer des dégénérescence de fin de
race on a couple en à couilles rabattues
des cousins encore plus Germain que des
de Bavière et Josette de plus
et puis merde quand par malheur un
berger allemand se faire si un bébé
tartare dans un berceau qui nous dit que
c'est pas le bébé qui a commencé
ce sont de quelle année est cet animal
qui est à l'instar de l'infirmière de
nuit de l'hôpital Marthe Richard le
meilleur ami de l'homme
aucune bête au monde si ce n'est
peut-être le morpion pubiens et aussi
profondément attaché à l'homme que le
berger allemand
aucune n'est plus dévoués attentive et
patiente avec les petits-enfants qui
peuvent sans danger lui tirer la queue
lui tordre la truffe lui bourrer les
oreilles de miettes de petits lui et lui
enfoncer du white-spirit dans le trou du
cul à l'aide d'un tuyau de caoutchouc
pour jouer au 24 Heures du Mans
catégorie clébard
et puis il faut le savoir le berger
allemand est le plus intelligent de tous
les chiens le mien par exemple refuse
absolument de faire ses besoins ailleurs
que sur la pelouse
les coins gravier lui les obligé de
trucs que je fais rien
que voulez-vous c'est une délicate il
sait cependant à quel point je
désapprouve se laisser aller Descatoire
alors à l'aide de ça que tremper dans la
peinture il a rédigé des petites
annonces au attention caca
qu'il plante à côté de chacun de ces
oublis
le jardin ressemble ainsi à un golf
miniature c'est très joli
je sais bien que de nombreux auditeurs
ne vont pas me croire mais je pose la
question parmi ces incrédules combien
vont à Lourdes sans rigoler
[Musique]
quant à ces féroces soldats je le dis
c'est pas pour café mais ils font rien
qu'à aboyer dans nos campagnes
[Musique]